amazon chef jeff bezos hat die
mondlandefähre blumen vorgestellt mit
der landefähre seiner firma blue origin
möchte er schon bald nutzlasten und
später astronautinnen und astronauten
zum mond bringen seine konkreten pläne
jetzt bei klicks und science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes
seines videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen
das war schon ein ausschlag jeff westers
arbeitet mit seiner firma blue origin
seit drei jahren an einer mondlandefähre
jetzt ist sie fertig und besser seien
große player
es ist zeit zum mond zurückzukehren und
dieses mal um zu bleiben sagte becker
bei der vorstellung zunächst soll die
fähre bis zu sechseinhalb tonnen lasten
auf den mond transportieren
manchmal stehen besser schon ein
bisschen im schatten von spacex gründer
in den masken aber amazon sind der chef
es ist mindestens genauso ärgert sich
auch mit blue origin also seiner firma
hat er schon erfolgreich seinen juden
shepherd rakete wieder auf der erde
landen lassen und kann sie wieder
verwenden für ihn ist der oberen des
weltalls der weg der menschheit und zwar
den den sie gehen muss nicht nur um den
klimawandel zu überleben auch um den pro
drogen durch asteroiden vulkanausbrüche
probleme bei der energieversorgung und
erdbeben zu entgehen im weltall liegt
laut bessers die zukunft weil wir hier
ohne durch naturkatastrophen gefährdet
zu werden uns weiterentwickeln können
seine mondlandefähre blumen ist für ihn
nur der erste schritt ein und er lobte
den us-vizepräsidenten mike pence für
seine idee bis 2024 wieder zum mond zu
fliegen ich liebe diese idee so bessers
es ist die richtige entscheidung sagte
er bei der vorstellung der landefähre in
washington und mit seiner mondlandefähre
will er den grundstein dafür legen sie
sollen zunächst eben nutzlasten mit
einem gesamtgewicht von 600 tonnen auf
dem mond transportieren allein vier
mondrover käme in der affäre unter um
den mond zu erkunden sie könnten zum
beispiel im vorfeld einer mondlandung
mit astronauten und astronautinnen nach
eis auf dem mond suchen und mit einer
modifizierten version von blumen könnte
dann auch ein erstes erkundungsteam auf
dem mond geschickt werden
das ist diese mission dann aber nicht
die vorbereitung auf eine mars mission
sondern er hat eine ganz andere vision
er denkt an weltraumstation wie in
interstellaren mit ganzen landschaften
und damit einem vollkommen ungefährdeten
zu hause es ist wie man seinen besten
tag das ganze jahr mein bestes für
besseres gibt es auf dem weg dorthin
zwei herausforderungen raumfahrt muss
billiger werden da sind er und ihnen
maske mit den ersten wiederverwendbaren
raketen und kapseln ja auf dem besten
weg und zweitens muss der bergbau und
der abbau von jeglichen ressourcen im
weltall beginnen und auch da wurde
gerade der erste schritt gegangen
luxemburg und die vereinigten staaten
von amerika haben ein abkommen zur engen
kooperation bei der kommerziellen
nutzung des weltraums unterzeichnet und
neben einigen anderen punkten geht es da
unter anderem um den bergbau im weltraum
noch mehr details zum projekt und ein
paar kritische anmerkungen gibt es bei
raumzeit block der zukunft nun länder
blumen space race fortan klicken
anschauen und natürlich raum zahlenblock
der zukunft abonnieren ansonsten bis
dann dran